okay well let's get started okay for for
those of people who are eavesdropping
here this is the the second pilot in our
experiment of doing open language design
reviews live-streamed so today we are
talking about design for chemistry and
often language and we're just doing what
what we do every day trying to do what
I've been doing for like 30 years now
making coherent and unified designs for
from language so let's see how we
managed to do on chemistry alright let's
get going okay let's get to work alright
so the let's see what we're looking at
here is the this wrapper that we're
calling molecule which does any of this
actually run not in the kernel right now
but in my package and everything in
there would evaluate well should we did
do you want to give me a version that
will actually run or should we see your
screen or should I just look at what
you've got here
well so I can so I could share my screen
to do a quick demo basically okay all
right fine so so let's just understand
what the the basic point is there are
various kinds of input for this molecule
thing and the main thing what is that
graph is that an ordinary graph or is
that right that is an ordinary graph I
haven't so we haven't nailed down the
design on that you mentioned wanting to
to be able to give it a graph and assume
so everything bobbins right right right
or perhaps be a little bit more
intelligent and and look at that and try
and put in hydrogen's where they might
be I say I say is that plausible oh I
see but so in other words the graph will
be a carbon backbone of some kind and
then it's like okay well would the
hydrogen's go is that the idea for ions
of some kind or that's what this is here
the biggest difference is not the exit
difference instead indistinguishable
what do you mean by that comment I mean
like in a cough that's always the one
vortex is never the same as it says
trivially they are to Adam to carbon
atoms that have the same Neutron number
are the same
former kinda mechanical point of view
that is certainly true but they appear
in different places so so so what for us
well so for yeah okay so from from a
language point of view though the big
big difference there is that in graph
the list of vertices needs to be
everything let's see if you run delete
duplicates on the list of vertices it
should have no effect you should not
have any duplicated vertices but with a
molecule that is not the case and so so
in a graph you lay out your vertices you
can give them any arbitrary Wolfram
language expression the easiest thing to
do is as the right right okay but so
here you're not naming the vertices at
all here you're just having sequential
indices for the vertices any solicit
well we could allow names for the
vertices I mean that's the same type of
issue that we have in for example neural
nets where we have the notion of a net
chain where we don't have where we just
have indices or a net trade I think can
also take an association concert where
it's actually naming the different
layers and so on so similarly here in
principle we couldn't and then you do
bookkeeping and you would you would find
you would assign formal charges in that
way so for example if I have a sodium
chloride thingy right which I with what
little chemistry I know I think does
that does that have a would that say na
with a with a plus one here or what
right and then so so that that's a
disconnected ion and you can also have
charges within a molecule like if you
look at TNT your nitro group you might
have a positive charge on one nitrogen a
negative charge on another oxygen and
this is we say it's the formal charge
because in reality the electrons density
and the partial charges are used for
that aspect of the modeling and modeling
the energy
okay so alright so there's probably some
other thing that we're going to need to
include here but let me understand some
other things so this six could equally
well be carbon as an entity is that
correct yes that are the string C
capital C the Atomics right right so I
mean along the entity line one thing
that would that would work there would
be an entity instance and ents the
instance of the atom carbon of the
element carbon with a formal charge and
an isotope and right that is a
reasonable thing I mean I okay so that's
an alternative to this association here
right right so I mean now let me point
out in this association this minus one
you should also at least support you
know electron charge as a unit there
right yes um and you know with isotope
is that the right name for that we say
isotope I mean that's that's really I
mean it's the unfortunate it's not the
atomic mass would you so another option
would be what we use in chemical data is
non-standard isotope number the heck
does that mean I mean what is it the
word non-standard isotope number right I
mean what what is there a notion of an
isotope number or what it's the mass
number okay it's usually called mass
number is that right power I believe
number exactly exactly
nucleons no no okay so mass number yeah
that's the number a fine so I mean no
unfortunately if somebody actually sees
this they will be confused if it doesn't
say um I mean it might need to say
isotopic mass number or something which
is very long but it just really matter
how long it is
um that that I think would be good
because in chemistry applications it's
you know carbon 13 that's important or
carbon 12 when you're dealing with
atomic structures and things like that
you're not worried about the natural
abundance yeah yeah right right right I
mean you actually want right but I mean
this is okay but the next question is
this I I am NOT a big believer in this
really wacky property thing but let's
let's keep going on these other so we're
talking now about the entities and we're
saying their variety of forms that they
can be given in including potentially an
entity instance or this association is
that the idea right and I don't know if
you want to talk about this now but
there that did bring up the point of to
what degree do we need to match the the
syntax or the names of properties from
chemical data where there is a
precedence whereas if in the molecule
which like what so like in chemical data
there's non-standard isotope numbers
there's should probably change that
iMovie should probably also provide a
different name for that um and let's see
so atom positions in vertex coordinates
to distinguish between 2d and 3d and
chemical data whereas I believe Bob
would really prefer you might well we
coordinates might just seem more natural
than atom positions what do we call it
in chemical data atom positions in
contrast to vertex coordinates so those
two names don't tell you that one is 3d
and one is 2d until you list look at the
other kind of stupid yeah it's kind of
stupid um so you're proposing something
like atom coordinates or something right
and then and then we what's this list of
formal charges how does that work in
chemical data so it'll be a list of
integers as long as the list of atoms
and where's the list of atoms the list
of atoms is vertex types that's
horrifying right it's it's a real
hodgepodge of graph nomenclature and
chemistry right okay well so we need to
fix that I mean it's not really a huge
problem because we can
keep supporting the old names um but we
just have to alright so which one's of
these have you got a list of which ones
need to be rethought here no we don't ok
look at this molecule thing do we really
want to use the name molecules the
actual as opposed to molecule object to
some such other thing I mean laxity
molecule what are we calling this didn't
we have another name for this but we
were look we were doing a molecular
structures we started chemical structure
and then we moved to molecular structure
and ie that's better
what why would that what's what's wrong
with that I just like the way that
molecule rolled off the tongue is why I
well it's it's a cool thing but I'm I'm
just concerned I don't know but it's a
molecule No
so that's so sometimes it has a charge
it's not technically a molecule by iux
standards and if it's if it's a if it's
a disconnected structure it's not
technically a molecule by by u-pack
standards all right but ok but let's
take a look at these things so this this
bond so this thing here will be
presumably equivalent to one you know an
undirected edge in a graph yes
yes ok but you've got to annotate this
now Roger I think that you had I mean
you've been wanting to annotate edges on
graphs for a while right
oh sure that was a mute I mean we do
that's what property is for so they have
an open-ended set of annotations well so
you can do that right I hate this name
property we really should come up with a
better name um yeah it should be
attribute
but someone yes that was taken 30 years
ago exactly for something completely
marginal I don't know how marginal it is
but okay in a case in any case let's but
yeah so now but but besides that there
is an open-ended set you can add however
many that you want okay so if you have a
meaning to double for instance or there
might be some other kind of you know
edge they mean very different things
depending on what it is that you model
okay so if I have an edge I can have a
list of name value pairs is that right
yeah okay but so what would you do in
the case of double would you say double
arrow true or what would you say double
bond arrow true no and so you would say
bond order goes to double or yeah okay
cuz they're so they're different is that
is that what it's called bond order
that's really confusing I mean
especially when you've got a
counterclockwise running around no bond
order is the accepted term for the
multiplicity of a bond between covalent
bond between two atoms but you just used
the word multiplicity as well is that an
alternative or you could say bond
multiplicity so so what for us well so
for Timothy yeah okay so from from a
language point of view though the big
big difference there is that in graph
the list of vertices needs to be
everything let's say if you run delete
duplicates on the list of vertices it
should have no effect you should not
have any duplicated vertices but with a
molecule that is not the case and so so
in a graph you lay out your vertices you
can give them any arbitrary wolfram
language expression the easiest thing to
do is as the rent right okay but so here
you're not naming the vertices at all
here you're just having sequential
indices for the vertices any solicit or
we could allow names for the vertices I
mean that's the same type of issue that
we have and for example neural nets
where we have the notion of a net chain
where we don't have where we just have
indices or a net trade
can also take an association concert
where it's actually naming the different
layers and so on so similarly here in
principle we could name the atoms would
we ever wanted well I so I think you
would you might want to have a tag for
the atom bob has successive experience
in modeling and you you might want to
keep track of the molecule of an atom
from one transformation to another right
often that's the case it's much more
convenient to refer to an atom by a name
that you've given it or that's been
assigned rather than trying to always
count and where where does it fall
because well you know right yeah when
you got okay
you'll the position can change but but
okay but so so there's two ways we could
imagine doing that one is the whole
thing turns into an association and
everybody has a name and those names
could be sequential integers that could
be names like you know gym or something
um but here I mean what what you're
saying here is that otherwise an atom is
specified by its atomic number that's
the generic way to specify it
what is the formal charge is that an
ionization thingy or what is that yes
it's so it's not so yeah it is an is an
ionization state it's not technically
the charge that would be there it's if
you took all of the charges of a bond
and split them evenly all the electrons
of a bond and you split them evenly and
then you do bookkeeping and you would
you would find you would assign formal
charges in that way so so for example if
I have a sodium chloride thingy right
which I with what little chemistry I
know I think does that does that have a
would that say na with out with a plus
one here or what right and then so so
that that's a disconnected ion and you
can also have charges within a molecule
like if you look at TNT your nitro group
you might have a positive charge on one
nitrogen a negative charge on another
oxygen and this is we say it's the
formal charge because in reality the
electrons density might redistribute
these charges in a way that's not as
entirely localized as we
say for a drawing or for bookkeeping
purposes but it's it's a useful tool for
for representing the molecule it's it's
not necessarily indicative of what the
actual chart
a little modeling in the past
charges are used merely for bookkeeping
on valence and partial charges are kept
for the actual partial charge for some
columbic calculation for example sorry I
missed a few words that because the
audio dropped out for some reason are
you saying there's a different thing on
formal charge that's something else
called partial charge yes yes and
molecular modeling partial charges are
used for the redistributed whole
molecular charge the sum should still be
zero for a neutral molecule for example
nitrogen's and oxygens and to have more
charge around them than carbon or
hydrogen do and it's important for a
docking studies for example you're
trying to drop an inhibitor into a
receptor site or something like that
because they interact with the
surrounding protein structure and the
partial charges are used for that aspect
of the modeling and modeling the energy
okay so all right so that's probably
some other thing that we're going to
need to include here but let me
understand some other things so this six
could equally well be carbon as an
entity is that correct yes that or the
string C right so I mean along the
entity line one thing that would that
would work there would be an entity
instance an ends the instance of the
atom carbon of the element carbon with a
formal charge and an isotope and and
right that is a reasonable thing I mean
I okay so that's an alternative to this
association here right right so I mean
now let me point out in this association
that's minus one
you should also at least support you
know electron charge as a unit there
right yes um and you know with isotope
is that the right name for that where
you say isotope I mean that's that's
really I mean it's the unfortunately
it's not the atomic mass would you so
another option would be what we use in
chemical data is non-standard isotope
number the heck doesn't that mean I mean
what is it the word non-standard isotope
number
right yeah I mean what-what is there a
notion of an isotope number or what it's
the mass number okay it's usually called
mass number is that right Bob I believe
so number
exactly exactly of nucleons no no okay
so mass number yeah that's the number a
fine so I mean unfortunately if somebody
actually sees this they will be confused
if it doesn't say um I mean it might
need to say isotopic mass number or
something which is very long but it just
really matter how long it is that that I
think would be good because in chemistry
applications it's you know carbon 13
that's important or carbon 12 when
you're dealing with atomic structures
and things like that you're not worried
about the natural abundance yeah yeah
yeah right right right I mean you
actually want right but I mean this is
okay but the next question is this I I
am NOT a big believer in this really
wacky property thing but let's let's
keep going on these other so we're
talking now about the entities and we're
saying their variety of forms that they
can be given in including potentially an
entity instance or this association is
that the idea right and I don't know if
you want to talk about this now but
there that did bring up the point of to
what degree do we need to match the the
syntax or the names of properties from
chemical data where there is a
precedence whereas if in the molecule
which like what so like in chemical data
there's non-standard isotope numbers
there's you should probably change that
but we should probably also provide a
different name for that um and let's see
so atom positions and vertex coordinates
to distinguish between 2d and 3d and
chemical data whereas I believe Bob
would really prefer you might well
coordinates might just seem more natural
than atom positions what do we call it
in chemical data atom positions in
contrast to vertex coordinates so those
two names don't tell you that one is 3d
and one is 2d until you list look at the
other kind of stupid yeah it's kind of
stupid
um so you're proposing something like
atom coordinates or something right and
then and then we what's this list of
formal charges how does that work in
chemical data so it'll be a list of
integers as long as the list of atoms
and where's the list of atoms the list
of atoms is vertex types that's
horrifying right it's it's a real
hodgepodge of graph nomenclature and
chemistry right okay well so we need to
fix that I mean it's not really a huge
problem because we can keep supporting
the old names but we just have to
alright so which ones of these have you
got a list of which ones need to be
rethought here no okay look at this
molecule thing do we really want to use
the name molecules the actual as opposed
to molecule object to some such other
thing I mean let's it a molecule what
are we calling this didn't we have
another name for this but we were look
we were doing a molecular structures we
started chemical structure and then we
moved to a molecular structure and ie
that's better
what why would that what's what's wrong
with that I just like the way that
molecule rolled off the tongue is why I
well it's it's a cool thing but I'm I'm
just concerned I don't know but the
molecule know so that's so sometimes if
it has a charge it's not technically a
molecule by how you pack standards and
if it's if it's a if it's a disconnected
structure it's not technically a
molecule by I you pack standards all
right okay but let's take a look at
these things so this this bond so this
thing here will be presumably equivalent
to one you know
an undirected edge in a graph yes yes
okay but you've got to annotate this now
Roger I think that you had I mean you've
been wanting to annotate edges on graphs
for a while right Roger that was a mute
I mean we do
that's what property is for so they have
an open-ended sets of annotations well
so you can do that right I hate this
name property we really should come up
with a better name um yeah it should be
attribute but someone yes that was taken
30 years ago exactly for something
completely marginal I don't know how
marginal it is but okay in a case in any
case let's but yeah so no but but
besides that there is an open-ended set
you can add however many that you want
okay so if you have a meaning to double
for instance or there might be some
other kind of you know edge they mean
very different things depending on what
it is that you model okay so if I have
an edge I can have a list of name value
pairs is that right yeah okay but so
what would you do in the case of double
would you say double arrow true or what
would you say double bond arrow true no
so you would say bond order goes to
double or yeah okay cuz they're so
they're different is that is that what
it's called bond order that's really
confusing I mean especially when you've
got a counterclockwise running around no
bond order is the accepted term for the
multiplicity of a bond between covalent
bond between two atoms but you just used
the word multiplicity as well is that an
alternative oh you could say bond
multiplicity that sounds much better to
me than bond order which sounds like
it's you know yes especially when we use
order to mean the order in which things
occur in a list which we do all over the
place so I would go for
bond type instead of bond multiplicity
because
you
it's more forgiving and we can abuse it
more um also I was just thinking for the
the whole thing itself instead of
molecular structure how about molecular
model because we're really talking about
models that's an interesting name
that's an interesting name and how does
that agree with I'm a molecular model or
molecule model sort of agrees with our
system model concept I guess I feel like
everything is inherently a molecule
model yeah when you make a graph it's it
is a model of a graph it is I mean what
do you mean it's a model of itself is an
abstract thing okay yeah mesh region no
but but we have but this is this is
realization is coming slowly to
everybody and it will be more by year
you know so distribution is a model but
we call it distribution well it's look
there is a perfectly platonic abstract
concept of a distribution that has
nothing to do the the the whether the
distribution has anything to do with
real world that's where modeling comes
in there's an abstract kind of thing it
is it's no a Gaussian is just a a
platonic thing out there in the abstract
formal world like the modern few what
the physical serious physical theory is
a set of mathematical axioms and a
correspond stable to the reality and
only vistas correspond stable something
becomes a model no
well so in statistics the notion of
model is different you know a model is
something that's usually a mechanism
that can reproduce the aspect that
you're interested in modeling that's
trained goes for system modeler yeah
it's not precise you know you can always
build a mortar we all agree that's what
a model is the issue which it says you
know this yeah right but the issue is
look is you know is all the integers
just an abstract thing or are they when
you have the integer - is it the
abstract interested - or is it a model
of the integer - I think one would
normally consider it to be the abstract
integer - no it's a it's a separate you
know getting into model theory and
modulo the non-standard arithmetic and
all this kind of nonsense but but Tim so
you know the point here is that one
could imagine okay so let's imagine that
somebody was actually doing an
experiment had was actually using um you
know so there's an interesting question
let's say that so Roger in the case just
for your example okay so some systems
and whatnot in books they don't call
things distribution they call them
models notion model and so on yeah I'm
aware it's a model that's the use of the
word model it's a slight abuse of the
word model as in it is a model is
something which makes a connection
between formal abstract world and the
concrete world of things that you that
exist in you know in physical reality
anyway let's let's not get go deep
philosophical on this I I personally
think molecular model or modelled
molecule model is an interesting
potential name for this but let's
continue go ahead this name you agree
it's a decent name yeah okay fine okay
so we didn't actually so that philosophy
discussion was irrelevant is that true
or is that yeah okay fine just checking
there okay so is it should it be
molecular or molecule model like a
molecular model sounds bad
probably although it has a certain you
know resonance with those things made of
wood and sticks and so on but it's not
too dissimilar exactly okay fair enough
okay all right what is a chiral Center
what is that it is an atom that has four
distinct ligands attached to it and they
appear in a particular order that give
it a handedness either right-handed or
left-handed they're not superimposable
but the mirror images are superimposable
and how many more graph theory I mean so
what you're doing there is you're
specifying an aspect of the graph that
is beyond in a sense you're specifying
not just the connectivity of the graph
but some topological data about the data
system yes and it's related to the
three-dimensional structure and it's
extremely important in biology and
pharmaceutical sciences okay but so so
just till I understand what I mean what
other topological constraints get put in
I mean that obviously at some level
ultimately you're gonna say this
molecule has its atoms at these
positions and then you can get even more
detailed than that um but what other
kind of gross topological constraints or
topological what other gross topological
information is that you have to specify
in in setting up the I think this is
about it I mean there's they're also
chiral axes and chiral planes we don't
need to worry about those too much
especially not for the first cut yeah
but what will they look like how many
how many atoms so in a chiral plane or
something cargo plane has to do
generally with rings and and one side
being different from the other and not
just a matter of flipping it over in
3-space chiral axes are related to a
chiral Center except it's it's not
around a single atom generally it's a
around a series of double bonds or from
one orbit so how would we specify that
so in this chiral santé thingy
sorry Carl what were you saying Carl
chiral chiral Center chiral axis again
it's four ligands around some core of
atoms okay so instead of a single atom
here you might have some list of atoms
there yes you would be saying and then
you have ligands attached to it you have
to specify those ligands and the order
in which they appear in sprites so those
are two examples of a hyper edge the
multiple vertices that have come
together to question about gulfs Roger
so this is a case I mean this notion of
ordering the edges that come in to a
vertex have we handled that in the case
of graphs or not no they're not ordered
you know I know you want that 48 for the
tree because our expression trees are
ordered trees right but so do we have a
solution for that in the case of trees
there is a solution in the sense that
it's completely specified by what what
it's connected to
Stephen the distinction here that we're
trying to make with the chiral Center is
that it's a connection between a 2d
topological representation of a molecule
and its three-dimensional shape and it's
very important if you have the atomic
coordinates there's there's no issue but
if you don't have the coordinates and
you need to make the distinction between
left and right-handed forms this is the
way somebody would do it in a database
of chemical structures for kima
informatics for example okay but fine
III get it but but so my question for
Roger is I mean actually for my you know
universe models and other things I'm
interested in the in graphs where there
is an ordering to the you know
connections to a vertex right do we have
a plan
Roger for how we represent any of that
stuff in graph
not really I mean one could make one but
it hasn't come up as an as a is a I mean
your universe model is not a big
application domain well the universe is
big you know but right but I mean
seriously it's it's sort of if you look
at it as graphs it doesn't make a lot of
sense one can still do it because you
can sort of model it with some property
that each of the edges out has so what
characteristic of a tree
I mean trees do naturally have ordering
on their on the edges that come out of a
node right I mean what kind of trees are
you talking about now expression trees
for example certainly yeah no I mean no
it's a trees it doesn't have ordering
you can have ordered trees okay but so
so in what sense all right so we've got
order trees but is there a notion of
ordering on a general graph that it's
like that is there a notion of ordered
graphs that is the analog of ordered
trees not that I'm aware of
okay I mean it's not a notion what would
it look like I mean is that a consistent
notion or is it is it even a nonsense
notion to begin with so around every I
mean one could do what just what I
described that you can give an
additional property to each edge that's
connected to it yes a number you know so
you get this order so you can choose to
then order by that number just by
looking at the labeling on the edges
right and you might be might be another
property there right but if you do for
example graph I mean for example graph
isomorphism or some other thing like
that or even I mean it may not be
consistent it may be that if you do
graph transformations of various kinds
that these orderings can't be made
consistent that there are only certain
operations that will preserve you know
for a tree it seems fairly easy to
imagine that you know gluing and
chopping off and gluing on sub trees
will allow you to preserve orderings
that's less obvious to me for graphs is
it okay it's been somewhat
of ultimate properties you want them to
have and but you can you know yeah I see
your consistency right but it can be
numbers for each you know they can be
ordered locally from the point of view
of every vertex you know and it's that's
basically it says from this vertex these
are the they're ordering the everything
coming out so that's similar to how how
this type of property is handled in the
the underlying library that we that we
use for the for the molecule it so in in
the example right there on the page page
the the atom that has atom index for
actually just has a property that is the
the CIP the the chirality we'll call it
the direction the handedness and it says
counterclockwise and then you look at
the bond list and you see that it's
bonded to atoms two five six and seven
in that order and then you from that you
can know you know this counterclockwise
thing this is I mean we are choosing in
this particular case to say I don't even
know this time what counterclockwise
could possibly mean here so what it
means okay so if so atom number four is
bonded to atoms two five six and seven
yep if you look along the axis from Adam
to to Adam for the remaining ligands
five six and seven are in a
counterclockwise direction oh gosh it
it's because the carbon atom is
tetrahedral in three-dimensional space
yeah I understand that but from okay but
so so counterclockwise means what does
it mean it means if you put you know
succulent pearl right you know polarized
light through it it will rotate and no
no it means going from the atoms from
five to seven to one or whatever the
order is from the example five six seven
yeah each you're tracing a clock
clockwise direction or a
counterclockwise direction around that
circle
okay and so that's these are the rules
that the chemists came up with back in
the 1950s to have a nomenclature for the
handedness of the molecules so so when
something is said to be a left-handed
you know whatever does that immediately
translate to that saying
counterclockwise or saying clockwise or
something precisely precisely and the
ligands the atoms get a priority
assigned to them based on what they're
attached to further out in the molecule
there's a whole graph theoretical basis
for this instead of rules for
disambiguating the the ligands you know
if you can disambiguate them by these
rules into four different ligands then
you can do the right the clockwise
counterclockwise and then give it a
symbol R or s for that direction
and so so the distinction there is that
there's there's an absolute handedness
to at any chiral Center and then there's
a local specification of it so in the
the molecule expression that we have you
specify locally what the what the the
handedness the parity around that Center
is but then what you the global
handedness is a computed property where
you have to look at each thing that's
attached to it assign a number and then
decide which which order those numbers
fall in right because you can make a
change remotely in the molecule and it
will change the priority assign to two
ligands so that's why we have to do it
locally here with clockwise and
counterclockwise but chemists have to
use a global representation which can be
computed from the structure by the way
do you guys think this is the right
ordering if I mean at a trivial level I
would have thought a better thing to do
would be but maybe if I'm wrong is to
have it by default look like this and
default it to either clockwise or
counterclockwise or is there no obvious
default
we could say that we always express it
in the clockwise order but it's not a
sensible default oh is that is that like
a totally random why would you choose it
default I'm Claire by the way I also
think we don't want to capitalize the c4
counterclockwise but that's a minor very
minor issue do we have a convention
elsewhere for when things are clockwise
versus counterclockwise
I mean clearly when we're having
coordinates surround a circle for
example those are counterclockwise
coordinates typically right yes you're
following the mathematical precedence in
the in the plane yes right but do we
have other cases where we're also doing
that Roger are there cases in region and
meshes mesh specifications where this
comes up and no but are polygons in the
graphics in a 3d graphics language has
when you need to speak about so not so
generally which way the polygon normals
assume right but you can speak of
orientation of any set any any geometric
set we don't do that like a rectangle is
not ordered yes okay but our polygons
are because we have different you know
we allow different colors on the two
sides so we need to be able to say which
right so what's the answer
so for them for the chiral Center I
would be opposed to having a default
because you could if you didn't put a
string there which by the way I do like
the string last as opposed to in the
middle of the way I have it there but if
you didn't put something there you're
specifying that we don't know the
information and that's a thing you can
you can have a mixture of molecules
where the handedness isn't decided or
you can you can write out the molecule
and just not know but then why do you
need to specify this Carlos interfere
not specifying the orientation cuz
sometimes sometimes you specifically do
you if you look on pubchem you'll find a
oftentimes for any molecule you might
find three distinct pages for it one
with counterclockwise one with clockwise
in one for an unspecified mixture and
when you say I'm specified why do you
need to bother in the molecule model to
actually give the chiral Center
specification why don't just leave it
out right
we would do that's what we are doing I
just okay I would that would be if you
didn't give it direction I would think
that you would assume that it was
unknown exactly I will get fine so fun
so you so the basic point is there's no
default um okay let's go on and take a
look at some of these other things and
then we'll loop back to the underlying
discussion okay so okay so this is where
we start going crazy um right okay so
Roger these are the analogs of graph ad
right okay for molecules so I have no
sense
there isn't a graph at what is this
vertex a is this really what I mean when
do you okay do you background noise
there um what I don't understand what
this these incremental things about
adding and deleting atoms and bonds and
so on is that a common operation very
much so especially in the molecular
modeling area drug design why I mean
it's like it's hardly easy to do in
physical practice right it's a it's a
hole okay go ahead
yes separate from chemical synthesis you
you have a drug you've got a drug
candidate and it docks fairly well in
the receptor site that you're trying to
inhibit and you see that there's some
space nearby that you want to fill up so
you want to use a larger group instead
of a methyl group that's there or if
it's just a hydrogen you might want to
replace it with a methyl group or an
ethyl group so you will want to add an
atom or replace an atom without having
to recreate your structure from scratch
and going through the whole process of
generating coordinates that you hope
will still fit most of the algorithms
that generate coordinates de novo do it
in a somewhat ad hoc way and as I was
telling Jason just the other day three
dimensional
coordinates for molecules molecular
models are generally hard-won and
modelers do not want to give them up
you know throw them away and recreate a
structure from scratch just to change a
carbon to a chlorine or something like
that okay but so why is it that we're
not letting people I mean we've got this
bothers me I mean especially the
description you just gave is not about
adding an atom by the way whoever's not
on mute and making background noise
could you try to what what does it make
sense Stephen the you were just
explaining that you would take a single
hydrogen and replace it with some methyl
group or something that's not an atom
add the name doesn't make sense okay no
that's not that would be a fragment ad
or something like that specifically but
one could change an atom and then add
hydrogens to film that they can but what
you're saying is basically you want a
subgraph you want to replace a subgraph
basically that's that's the basic
operation you're talking about yes in
the in the general case that's exactly
what's going on and granted I'm coming
from a lot of background historical way
that we used to do it molecular modeling
thirty years ago and and so on so a lot
of it has anything changed I mean to
some extent yes a lot of things have not
there's there's a lot of history a lot
of cultural baggage and the way things
have been named and operations have been
but but the basic point is that you're
saying that it's like for example if I
do a graph and what we haven't done in
in the case of graphs if I just make a
random graph you know and and it has a
certain layout and then I do a vertex
then I modify a vertex what we are doing
in traditional graph is completely real
relaying out the graph with the with the
new vertex configuration right so Roger
don't we have coming a thing where you
can lock some of the vertices in the
graph yes to that position how does that
just for layouts for I understand but
but this is that's what these guys care
about too because the layout the layout
is the physics sure exactly
um okay so how does it it what is the
what is our actual language design for
locking vertices so there is I can't
remember a hundred percent right now
because I want to see it sort of it's
not actually operating as we speak so
but the idea is that you can have vertex
coordinates and you can you know if you
want to lock something you specify the
things that you want to lock and or the
other way around you know I think we
need both ways you know I think we had a
design for this and I don't remember
what it is is it just that you give a
partial list of vertex coordinates you
know you need to say which once it is
that you give yeah I understand that so
it's an association of some kind right
that's what I was saying that you can
either lock things down or you can say
change only DS so I think both are
interesting because sometimes you know
often one is bigger and one is smaller
and you want to use the smaller so the
eye area right right fair enough okay so
with there's some design will have to do
on that but so the chemistry case what
we're really talking about is a sub
graph is getting replaced now
unfortunately our sub graphs are not
exactly named in the chemistry case
atomic num you faded hello
hello can hear me yes we can you were
saying in the chemistry case and then
you faded out oh did it hit it okay um
okay so my question is how are you
specifying an atomadd which where on the
molecule you're supposed to be adding
this well what we would do is when we
did it but most things TVs days are done
through a graphical interface but in
before we had those we had a
command-line interface we would say add
atom and we give them all accuse the
argument we would tell it what kind of
atom we were adding I'm gonna know when
it was attached so I'm sorry what was
that what was the where is it a numbered
atom it's enough depending on the
modeling system you are using it was
either a you know the atom index or in
the more recent ones the name assigned
to the atom okay fun dope but as we you
know that's a good reason to actually
have individual names for them if you
want exactly yes that's why we went to
atom names later on because it was just
much more convenient especially in
protein structures you could name it by
residue and then the standard name you
know C alpha Co you know and one so in
this case though I feel like atom at
acts exactly like vertex ed it adds the
atom but it doesn't create a bond and
then when you want to go and make a bond
you do bond ad and get the molecule and
then you can to indices really low-level
I mean doesn't it that's too low-level
chemists combine all of that into one
step so you may include the names of two
of the atom to which you're adding it so
the bond can be made and the default
would be a symptom we don't have it but
but but the problem Bob is we don't in
the current design and as Michael was
explaining you know quantum mechanics
tells us all the atoms are identical we
don't actually have names for these
atoms no but we we need to do something
about the either we have to give them
names or we have to do everything by
index and as Roger said names would be
much more convenient
well it depend at there sort of you know
sites that are particularly interesting
to have names yes her like landmarks
it's like we sometimes all cities are
equivalent but some of them have names
right so you can have you can have the
substructure bit defined by a pattern
and how exactly to enter that into to
the Wolfram language is something I'm
really interested in figuring out but we
haven't fully but so this is the same
thing as with with net you know with
neural nets and so on that sometimes the
ports are just specified by indices and
sometimes there are actual names
assigned to them and we've done that
typically by having I mean in this case
what we can imagine is that the
Association or the entity instance could
assign could have a name that's
associated along with these other things
like well it's not with bonds but we
could just have a name there that was
part of the so we can have two
alternatives we could either have an
association for the whole thing in which
case everything has a name or we could
give this particular element of that
list of vertices ie atoms and have a
name as part of that that make sense
right so you have a name key in that key
value along with for a charge and so on
so that means the vast majority of atoms
will not be named but a few will be and
those will be the ones that you actually
when you can refer to them by that name
right I could see see here's another one
you do that you can probably get a bunch
of other benefits like someone gives you
a molecule and highlight some sites that
might be interesting yeah if they have a
name you know maybe you want to see the
label for that name when you plot them
you know and you visualize them yeah
well that's a good point it's
highlighting of these chemical
structures does that is that something
that I mean in the case of graphs how
does the highlighting thing work so you
would say highlight graph of that graph
comma and then what I just give some
vertex numbers like that that's that
will work okay and what if I want to
give a bond or an edge then you give
edges there instead of vs. okay but so I
want to say for example the edge to
arrow I don't know what's connected to
blank would that work yeah
how did that work did that do something
to an edge was taking the highlighted
graph oh no but it's the highlighted
graph is okay the highlighted graph is
just a graph yeah but that's where you
took this input so I'm not sure yeah no
no no highlight graph is just a graph
yeah which is which is good and that's
the same thing that should happen for so
you're doing that with property rappers
and the graph is that correct Roger
that's correct
so we should either use the same
mechanism or a very similar mechanism in
the case of molecules because we're
definitely going to want some kind of
highlighting mechanism in the case the
molecules yeah so now in the case of a
graph do we have sub graph replacement
yet mmm no right so sub graph I mean in
principle I might say this sub graph
involving these three vertices gets
replaced by this other sub graph right I
mean you can you could pick it out I
mean if you want the various go ahead
tell me the sub graph that is associated
with vertex number three or something
how do I get out of the sub graph and
they seem tight okay what do I say
common three yeah you can say a bunch of
vertices or you can you could do an edge
right 3 goes to blanks yeah that's not a
very exciting sub graph I want to know
what's connected yeah tangling legs of
well pick pick some more vertices but
how do you find the ones that are
connected first neighbors to three they
they you know neighborhood graph okay so
if I say if this their neighborhood Gulf
neighborhood graph of percent 3 comma 3
yeah
okay and can I go to levels out or
something here yeah
I can't remember the arguments but cool
wonderful intuition the so if I say
vertex labels are automatic here hmm
very cool
okay all right so that's the kind of
thing that we want to have okay so what
would be the our log of neighborhood
graph is that the relevant thing so I'm
still kind of confused here because what
we're gonna want to do in the chemical
case what you're basically saying is I
want to take a sub graph and I want to
replace it with another sub graph that
correct yeah so that to me still sounds
like a separate thing then then then
there's just the base bond adding bonds
adding atoms if we don't want to make
heads for those we could just allow them
to manipulate the structure like atom
add would be a pen to molecule part one
find out likewise but but okay a pen two
is even more horrifying do you mean
append or do you mean append to that's
something we need to sort out whoa you
couldn't I mean you could do either no
you don't it's not a value molecule
molecular structure is in no way an
l-value
okay so you understand that you can't
you can't assign if you you take it and
you append to it and you get another one
of it so to speak back into some object
right I would go with the traditional
paradigm in Wolfram language that you
get a copy back and you get a new thing
yeah I think so I may be crazy to do
anything other than that but okay but so
this family of things about so one point
we got to understand this family of
things is going to be about sub graph
manipulation in the molecule we don't
yet completely understand this but let's
keep going because I want to see what
the scope of the things we're dealing
with and I have no idea what molecule
join is supposed to do is that just put
two molecules just living in the same
house type thing or what yes so they
would mean yeah just adding to it would
be one molecule to disconnected the
structure
well I don't yeah yeah I we need to be
able to work with more than one molecule
at a time in the same physical space as
it were but I don't think we need to
make an object that houses them together
well so wait you're talking about the
coordinate system that's defined so once
you do if you can actually find the
energy minimization thing to actually
get the coordinates for the atoms then
the issue is if you've got you know two
water molecules sitting there or or some
cluster of twenty water molecules
sitting there you might want to specify
the coordinates of each individual water
molecule relative to its center of mass
or relative to the central mass of the
whole cluster and you're saying how do
you do that that right no I wasn't going
there what I was saying was you want to
be able to measure things between two
models of you know two molecules you
want to be able to superimpose them view
them together in the same space and the
same graphics object in your notebook
but they still have their own
independence from each other I do you
know okay but take the case that I was
talking about because we need is it a
pure view compute view thing all right
some extent it's very much a pure view
thing but you also need to be able to do
quantitative things between the two
structures in the same space when you
say in the same space you mean with atom
coordinates yes it's our absolute
relative - yes so embedding them in the
same space okay yeah - take my example
okay of the cluster of twenty water
molecules that that is sort of another
case of what you're talking about all
right so so in a sense what you're
saying is that that say you know when
you say molecular structure or molecular
model here that would be the question is
what happens when you feed in molecular
model molecular models and how do you
well you know when we get to atom
positions what what are they relative -
are they relative to a central mass or
are they what are the absolute atom
positions generally they've just been
absolute positions it measured in
angstroms
and they only become the absolute
location in your coordinate frame only
becomes important when you Sneed to work
with a second set from another time I
get it but okay one trivial question did
did the world of Si and pin John listen
to it making it nanometers or is it
always acts Tom's for the rest of time I
think it's angstroms it was when I moved
out of chemistry 15 years ago anybody
Michael okay in any software that I've
encountered you either put them in
angstroms or bores nanometers is isn't
isn't really used for these use for
molecular orbital calculations right
Jason what other kind of calculations
aren't there yes yeah boards I forgot
about that one for Gaussian okay
formally allowed to be used with Si in
the areas where they have been
historically used in other words the SI
people gave up on trying to push that
okay fair enough
okay but so so so we are going to
standardize on angstroms is that the
idea is that going to be the default if
you give a naked number fine so
traditionally in chemical data we've
we've plotted in in Pico meters we and
we return values and picometers just
because then your image size and your
plot range are on the same order of
magnitude so hundreds oh that's
horrifying
what what why did we choose Pico meters
that just seems crazy I mean why is
picometers useful to anybody other than
that you've got things in hundreds which
why do we care I mean why does that
that's that's having a pixel per is the
concept of pixel per hang Strom or
something pixel per Pico meter for a
long per fortnight yeah I can't speak to
why it was it was chosen that's that's I
speculated that that was the reason it
seems crazy to me I think it was because
was si but the people who did it I don't
think her around anymore
right well okay but so so is that
something we can change or is that going
to mess everything up
well it's certainly something we can
change if we change the name of the
property of the atom positions property
right right okay so that's a separate
issue that we're gonna have to address
okay but but so now okay so we don't
fully understand this business about tum
okay so the next question here is what
happens when there are multiple I mean
in your molecular model setup there is
nothing wrong with having multiple
disconnected molecules sitting there
right but there's no special
representation for them and when you do
that if you have molecules which all
have a named site on them how do you
deal with the merging of those molecules
with their name site if they if they
both have a named site called you know x
marks the spot or something or you know
active site or something like the
binding site let's say they've you know
you have a molecule which has the word
binding site the name binding site for
some position on the molecule then you
you know join that cluster that with a
molecule which has the same thing how do
you do it we yes and we probably do it
very similarly to a way joint across
does with datasets or associations okay
what what happens with graphs Roger when
you join two graphs how do the how do
the vertices get renamed so there is a
there is I mean that that depends on
which joining operation you use first of
all because they're different ways of
joining them okay okay is there a graph
join that just does a generic no there
isn't okay what what are these like a
graph Union for instance a graph
intersection and it's right
okay so graph Union Gulf intersection is
not gonna be problematic but graft union
what does that do does that merge what
does that do to the the vertex which is
named the same in the two graphs it
probably merges it right so it just
gives it the same it gives it the union
of the edges that that first open earned
details
see yeah I see so that's so that
literally does do so that never has a
problem with two copies of the same
thing
no but in the case of molecules we will
have that problem right okay so what you
want is sort of like a disjoint Union
yes but but but that has to as as Bob is
saying that there's got to be some
renaming mechanism yeah even when you
have that you know there is always like
for graphs there is always a canonical
underlying thing called an index
yeah and that's managed by the system so
there's always an index associated with
it you know it has a named expression
whatever you used and label says the
third thing which is purely for display
purposes yeah okay fair enough but what
you're saying is I mean we haven't had
to address the question of renaming I
mean I know I've done this in in graph
rewrite type stuff of having to rename
vertices in a graph and for example if
you do a graph rewriting yeah I mean
anytime you do graph rewriting you have
to rename vertices and the join across
convention involves taking the names and
let's say you have two associations with
names a and B don't you end up with a
final association that has name list a B
is that correct or something like that
it uses the name of one Association the
left or Association know what I don't
think it has to do that right they trace
back to contain missing elements when
generated so this is by the way somebody
is making a lot of background noise
again um
they but so it is a key collision
function there yeah so do you
it sort of delegates back to you okay so
we would have to do a similar thing if
we have some kind of molecular join
right and and also it kind of implies
that the molecule
themselves might have a name that could
be used to disambiguate you know see one
that's coming from both both molecules
and we had not yeah we haven't try to it
yes we had up Troy talk to talk about
names it depends on your specific
implementation of modeling so so so
Roger in this case of system models
there you've got two resistors and they
have different names right how are we
handling that but when you instance it
you give it another name like four
resistors are okay and it's in its own
namespace so if we have a system model
and it's a resistor with all of its
various some you know dotted names and
so on how does it how do you specify the
instance of the resistor well do you get
it back when you when you when you do
this you you gonna get an instance of it
what function when I do system model of
that well it only happens when you well
that no no I'm sorry when you do a
system model that's for querying but if
you're trying to put them together in a
model to create the new model yep then
then you will get you know in the
instance of it okay what's the language
level representation of that you you
know if you if you look at create system
model or connect system model connect
then you see that you give the variables
yourself system model connect what you
have to go to the source
Ezard in dr. tools yeah
though whether we have a suggestion I'm
noticing from somebody watching this
twitch stream about tum if there are
multiple matches if you're trying to do
a match it's a good point that one wants
to do pattern matching it's not obvious
if you want to replace an active site
you've got a collection of molecules and
you want to replace the active site by
something else there are two different
things you might want to do you might
want to replace molecule ones active
site with something or you might want to
as a pattern replace all active sites in
that cluster with something did that
seem sensible Bob looking mute button
there yeah that's very sensible right
there's the whole question of molecule
patterns and working with them as well
Roger this doesn't seem to be no it's
there but it's just generally not
connect what what is the hold on okay
so regarding atom names given to atoms
or names given to sites although so I
don't know how we would name a site in
the the molecule expression that we were
working on guys you're saying so what is
a site a site is not just a single
atomic position but it might be for
example a I am so it's called connect
system Auto components okay what is its
name again connect system model
components okay but I want to come back
to this thing about naming okay hold on
look we're gonna cut to this in a second
but but just let's talk about um this
issue so you've got a radical or
something what I don't even a group
whatever but I'm call it a functional
group that's the name I was looking for
right okay so if you want to name a
functional group how do you do that well
so what I would think would be
substructure find and then you do
molecule and then you have
representation of the functional group
no but I understand that but the problem
is with this thing you know I want to
give a specific name to a whole
functional group how would I do that in
this representation so I would make a
property for the atoms like I'm Zoe in a
data packet Lee you have memberships so
where it belongs to this group blah yeah
I mean but I throwing in things like
that chiral center why not throw in some
more annotation I mean that chiral
Center is basically collecting you know
random atoms and say you're together now
for some purpose right we would do the
same thing for an active site and you
would define it by you know you would
name all of the atoms involved in that
site they don't need to be connected
it's a very natural thing to do for a
protein for example okay but so what
would be a generic name just like you
have chiral Center there is there a
generic name for a you know special
piece of a molecule where we could say
this special piece is an active site and
it involves the following atoms for
example yes something like that and you
can have what wasn't the right name for
special piece you could call it
functional group no that that's too
narrow and it generally implies that
they're all connected Jason I think we
need to come up with a name active site
is too specific to proteins molecular
components or something I don't know
something like that we yes we need to
name a collection of atoms for whatever
reason whatever purpose the modeler has
in mind I don't know I guess okay I'll
have to think about this I do I guess I
don't see the reason for that that that
has to live inside the molecule
well it seems convenient to me because
that way we can generalize your chiral
Center notion to other kinds of random
things that are needed for random
purposes by it by other you know for
example that might be for example I
could imagine a case where but maybe
this is getting into a different thing
where where some sub part of the
molecule okay so here's a question let's
say you've got some fancy modeling
system and it has managed to
successfully position a bunch of atoms
in the molecule but other ones are
hanging out on position
for example let's say there are some
that are pretty much fixed in position
and there are other ones that you are
modeling you know the vibration of for
example I could imagine you wanting to
pick up you know it's basically just a
way of naming I mean I is there an hour
log of this in graphs Roger yeah well I
was just getting to there is a lot of
ways to compute various sub graphs okay
so we have a whole huge family a lot of
it comes from social network analysis
you know to find clans and cliques and
and so on
yeah there's a whole whole big group of
those and they all return a list of
vertices which defines the the sub graph
they do right yeah and we need something
analogous here and I'm just not sure
what the name for it should be at this
point but wait a minute those are the
things that are coming out of a graph
right they don't live within the graph
right I mean so given given an animation
within the graph one of those functions
might be lazy in terms of computation
and do very little and just return the
result of you know result return that
result so okay let's come back to your
connect system model components so what
is this what is this thing doing here do
we have examples here
all I need to look at your screen yeah
you're looking at them okay but what
does this do what does it mean how does
it but you're not showing identical
things you're showing things which
already have unique names here right so
you're not addressing the issue that we
were talking about right wait you've got
a single resistor here correct yes but
once you wire them up that resistor it
still is going to be a unique when it's
wired into this bottle yep
want to be able to modify that resistor
and you can't of course resistor that
everybody else using of course right so
I'm asking you how does it disambiguate
the names as it puts two resistors into
the circuit okay so you you've already
say hold on stop scrolling yep
the R and the L and a C and a G those
are given by you those are names that
you've chosen when you were a modeler
they're fine
okay I see but that so this is saying R
is an instance of yes that's right and I
you know if I need it to ours I have to
call them like R 1 and R 2 no I
understand that but when when you
connect the components if one of them if
both of them had a thing called R what
does it do does it give an error or what
does it do
yes that would be an error because you
you give them names here and you've
given the same name twice okay well I
mean I think whatever the renaming
mechanism is I mean one could imagine a
situation in which it will be quite
useful I mean if I was building some
giant I don't know you know cascading
amplifier II thing right that had
multiple stages wouldn't it be really
annoying to have to make up my own
separate names at every so you use
arrays of them so yeah there are ways to
streamline that when you're gonna use
many many of them what does an array of
those look like instead of it is it is
it a set of string names or is it
something different
would you just declare it to be an array
of a certain length so then you every
part of it is index like an array so R
square bracket 1 or s bracket 2 and so I
don't God okay yeah I mean that's the
right it's a little bit I mean that's
not okay so we have not really addressed
this question of overlaying graph I mean
this is this is the nasty underside to
everything to do with graphs is this
whole naming business no it's not really
well what do you mean I think I mean the
problem in language design way it's why
you have avoided it but no it's not
really a problem in grout well what do
you mean it's not a problem you've got
to have an actual name that's the way
you refer to the vertex yeah so it's the
fact that the name is arbitrary and the
name has to be rejiggered when you you
know joint merge two graphs seems you
know is there an elegant way to do that
how to automatically generate new names
right well so I mean one obvious way to
do it is to simply take the implicit you
know if you have a list of graphs you
take the implicit index of the whole
graph which is the you know sequence
number of the graph in the sequence of
graphs you're giving together with the
index number of each vertex and you
start having I mean conveniently
obviously we can have arbitrary
expressions as the names of our vertices
so we can say you know 1 comma 7 on
things means vertex 7 of graph 1 and
things like that but it hardly seems
beautiful now in a scheme the I mean for
for graphs there will always be an index
underlying that and that's always an
integer and it's always sort of starting
one going to lose for our graphs or for
graphs in the world and there now for
our graphs you know and that's
implicitly sort of in the world as well
but it depends on what case you know if
it turns out to be true that you know
the whole universe and space-time is a
graph I you know it will be almost
comical I mean that's that's the case
one of the reasons that's hard to get
one's head around Stephen there are all
kinds of things going on I know 150
potential graph languages will graph
domains of applications yes they all
have their own little things going on of
what do you mean but but but does
anybody have a clean solution does any I
mean this particular issue of merging
two graphs and renaming things is there
any I mean you know I would have thought
that over the years we would actually by
now know all possible solutions to that
and I think I know a few and none of
them are very nice
so I'm asking is there some brilliant
you know innovative solution to that
that you know that I'm not aware of or
are they all kind of yucky solutions but
see that I think the problem is that you
kind of want to have the cake and eat it
too so you know and so depending on what
your goal is there might be
that look great and some that don't look
so great sometimes you want to be able
to infer where they came from right so
so you might want an operation that's
similar to flatten because like in
flatten what you're doing is you know
let's say you've got I mean you know in
flatten you can either know you know
with with you of whatever it is you know
a thing like this right you either know
where everything came from and
everything has its position or you can
go ahead and say flatten it in which
case you have the content but you don't
know the you know you don't know the
provenance in the same way and I could
imagine the same thing for for graph
labels graphing a you know names of
vertices and graphs you have an
operation like a graph flatten type
operation that will simply take all of
the do something similar to this right
because this started by having in this
case the elements here are you know the
two to one elements here but in this
case that's been flattened to just a
single index does that make sense yeah I
mean that seems like do we have such an
operation for rina relabeling renaming
you know re numbering the vertices in a
graph yeah effectively what is it no I
mean it will it it will give a sort of
flatten has just you know from 0 to 8 or
from 1 to 8 as an index right yes and
then the former one has a vector plus
exactly exactly exactly what we're
talking about here for craft merging
graph joining go ahead yes and actually
you put in a function which I've written
so many times which is called mixed base
or whatever it's called mixed radix
mixed radix so you can from you know if
you knew the original structure you can
easily reconstruct ok right when you
look at that but you know I understand
but it's a thing for doing its what
Fortran used to do or whatever it's it's
the thing for unrolling arrays and to
flatten things right okay so all right
so that that's a separate issue and that
we should talk I mean that that's a
separate thing that we should have on
the agenda is some kind of graph
relabeling graph flattening I mean it's
an interesting
whether we can actually have graph
operations operate on these molecular
model constructs I think there's a lot
of analogy there and the question is can
we actually get away with using the same
namespace could we use vertex add an
edge ad on a molecule yeah right the way
vertex ad works remember is vertex ad is
labeling the vertex by giving its vertex
name right by giving the name of the
vertex but we don't have other than the
whoops vertex ad other than the okay so
vertex ad makes the graph by adding the
vertex to the graph G okay the problem
here and then we'd have edge ad as well
but but what you'd have to do here is
write ad and that's you lower level to
do four molecules yeah they are here by
the way because this is also they are
here because you might have sort of in a
loop where you incrementally construct
the graph that's why there is no system
like that she's rare for a molecule is
that correct despite your nested way of
constructing an alkane here right but I
just want to see a reason not to allow
low level manipulation no but you can
always do it by taking the thing out of
the molecular struck out of the
molecular model and just manipulating it
right because it is just an expression
structure great you just append but but
will this actually work because yeah but
this would work I mean edge add I don't
see why you shouldn't allow edge add and
vertex ad to work on this modular model
but let's we need to keep going and just
take a look here some of the other
things so this is the other thing you
know Steven is you have to worry about
3d coordinates versus to need
coordinates versus any coordinates at
all and inherently graphs don't have
positions for the vertices until you
embed them or do a layout whereas most
people at least okay one world of
modelers don't rely on it the other half
of the modelers do rely on
three-dimensional atomic positions
look when you
put in a smile string that nobody's ever
seen before you don't know the positions
right and generally you don't care but
at some point you might want to put that
into three-dimensional space and from
that point on everything you do with
that molecule you will expect 3d
positions to go along with it and if
you're adding an atom to it you need to
you need to include a position those you
need to include a position for the atom
or or then you optionally will be able
to compute it from how you attach it by
the modu are we imagining then that in
this thing that is turning into
potentially a pretty big Association or
a pretty big collection of things an
entity instance that the actual
positions might be listed here in the
vertex list we well Jason and I have
been keeping them in a separate list
that's named rather than keeping each
rep as an option than to the why well I
do that I mean what what because in this
case where you want partial you know for
example if you want partial locking you
know of positions right it'd be more
convenient to annotate some of these
with that position and leave the other
ones undetermined than to start messing
around trying to say oh you know index
number 17 has a position but index
number 18 doesn't have a position yeah
if we go that route I agree putting them
with the atoms is probably the better
way to go and then so I would see locked
or not locked but do we have any
mechanism sorry in graphs
Roger do we have any mechanism to give
the embedding coordinates yeah you know
not with the eye actually you can do it
with property right you could do with
property and say vertex position are
such other things that's it yeah that's
it if you want to use the rapper style
you know in line yes property is it
right but that will work just as so in
this case you know it might be
convenient to annotate the the you know
atom list or it might be convenient to
have a separate separate annotation you
know a separate thing so maybe both of
those could be considered although we
have to decide what the canonical
formation whether the canonical form
involves annotate
positions which I have to say seems to
me to make quite a bit of sense do you
ever have to annotate bonds with
something that has been computed about
them isn't that how your whole I mean in
the in the world of orbitals and things
isn't there just a ton of annotation
that you might have to give in my
experience we haven't worried about
annotating bonds other than the the bond
order of the bond type okay what about
you Jason
well I mean so in the underlying library
the way that a chirality is handled is
either through an atom annotation or a
bond annotation but it's it's kind of
ugly and so we need to to process that
before okay I don't I don't care about
that but let's let's have a quick look
through because we're about to run out
of time here um so these are the
properties of the molecular model rate
and there will be on the order of a
hundred or more of these things that you
could commute compute but then so then
there's the question of what about when
you can give options to them like that
smiles there are many options that you
can give for smiles but we don't I don't
know of any examples in the language
where you have an object and you give it
a string arguments to get back a problem
they're like property attributes right I
mean they're like what date that
population was measured for and things I
think okay so when you when you query an
entity just as ahead like calling entity
value under the under the hood you can
give it options like that so that
correct Michael is that the way this
works they're more or less I mean
they're more like a property entity I
mean it would be more in the spirit if
there would be an additional header on
both also then linearised yes I
understand so there's another concern
here which is that these atom positions
are hardly to not mix too many metaphors
set in stone so to speak in the sense
that these are you know these will
typically be the output of some random
molecular modeling program right right
and we we wanted to give them the option
of making more you can I mean I've got a
function and oh maybe somehow like the
center of mass is in the zero
or what's I think usually yeah in the
center of mass or is it simply the
average of the coordinate positions is
zero which is a very different thing
because there might be rhenium atoms
okay what should it be I mean
particularly if we want to be able to do
computations that involve you demean for
those guys and see what it says
yeah fine the UM um not zero that
molecule is in weird motion of some kind
um well I don't know if I would call it
motion I mean it's just in a different
place in space that's all yeah okay but
but um okay but we do need to
standardize that and for example when
you want to look at molecular you know
vibrations and things don't doesn't it
matter that you've got that thing lot
you know you know doesn't it matter that
you know where the center of mass is no
yeah also when you do know what what I
mean I mean constellation invariant know
so when you do molecular vibrations you
actually filter out those coordinates
you do a coordinate transformation and
you take six coordinates out and so you
only nicely work an internal coordinates
usually but then you have to project
back and you have to know where things
are when you project back is this for
calculating the actual physical
vibrations of the atoms in space or just
the delinquencies I would have thought
the physical vibrations in space no ok
so we'd like you wanted to do an
animation or something like that right
oh you're right obviously dynamics right
okay let's let's keep looking just for
words here we've we've clearly got a lot
more to do here yep having coordinates
what is this okay what is this embed the
molecule
so this is actually doing molecular
structure computation is that correct
right so it uses a computer distant
distance bound matrix where where atoms
that are two or three bonds away from
each other need to be within a certain
distance of each other tries to generate
random coordinates to fulfill that
matrix and then uses some some clean up
code to try and make it into a more
total structure just to understand so we
got a lot of random functions running
around here
I mean how successful can this be if I
give you a random hundred at a molecule
and I've given you roughly the right
structure can you actually evolve it to
something that is a pretty accurate
molecular structure using this so if you
give us 3d coordinates to start with
that are not bad then then we can go on
to the the second thing which is
optimizing via force field and come up
with something that's that's that is
pretty good so let me understand what I
mean just as a name though don't call it
optimized geometry okay that will be at
least give a sense that it's related to
molecules right right it's going to that
will not survive I don't know what it
should be called but that's not it okay
it's Steven for your example 100 random
molecules and it depends on how they're
connected if it was one big long chain
with no branching it would be hard to do
with the distance geometry approach but
if it was a structure that had rings and
things like that and branching then it
wouldn't be that hard again you know the
hardness is somewhat subjective okay but
given a smile string doesn't the smile
string contain some information on the
geometry
no just the connectivity just the
connectivity and the more connectivity
you have of course the more rigid the
structure becomes and the much easier it
is for distance geometry to do its job
so so in the case of okay but so our
graph layout for example if you just
apply our graph layout to the implied
connectivity
from a smile strain does it produce
something that is vaguely like a
molecule or hopelessly I mean Oh is
there a virtually generally hopeless
because you know for molecular
structures a six membered ring you
expect to look like a hexagon on bond
angles the I understand so here's a
question do we have a version of graph
layout that forces the typical distance
between nodes to be the same in other
words graph layout has some vague you
know spring type reasons so there are
many different algorithms of course one
general one is called spring electrical
indeed which is what which which has
that general approach right it tries to
keep things roughly the same length
mm-hmm yes you have a spring and an
electrical repulsion yep and I can get
something reasonable with spring
electrical and bedding if you add in
dummy atoms before embedding and then
remove them so that that forces you know
two atoms to have a hundred and twenty
degree angle in between them because you
had this dummy an atom you take
something like the valence of the thing
you add dummy atoms to go to the valence
to my force these angles is on the Oh
what right but so in I mean so having
something which does a first cut of what
the molecular structure I mean so that
sounds like a reasonable procedure and
not totally ridiculous algorithm for
getting a first cut for what the
structure is that's true well that's a
2d structure I see why can't you do the
same thing in 3d spring electrical works
in nad right to do this I mean Jason has
external particular ketchup good well
wait a second but Bob was just
explaining that if I give you a whatever
a hundred a is called you know that big
long chain of stuff right then it just
won't work
geometry would have a hard time if I
could perceive that that was just a
chain I could use an algorithm to
generate the positions with no trouble
at all you know completely except that
if I might say so I mean a chain is
gonna be like a snake it's gonna you
know knowing what it's sort of optimal I
mean I don't know I have no idea what an
actual you know it's like a you've got a
giant polymer molecule it doesn't
actually it's very floppy inflexible
right it is but what you want to do is
avoid self crossing paths if you will
through space but what's the right
answer for a random long polymer yeah
that that's a very reasonable thing to
build and then if you wanted something
with some more rigid or more refined
structure then you could say I want it
fully extended or you know I want okay
so this this leads to another problem so
the other problem is there isn't a
unique answer right that's right right
it's it's a hard problem
embedding large molecules but I'm saying
it's not even clear what the unlike for
some of these other purposes where there
is a you know an energy minimum and all
this kind of thing if I mean you know in
the case of the big long snaky you know
polymer it's a very flat landscape isn't
it it is it is it's a very large
catchment region with a lot of little
dimples at the bottom that are very
shallow and you know any one is not very
different from any other one so you know
we could easily generate something that
that would satisfy most people and if it
doesn't then they have the opportunity
to refine it work to try to generate
another so what you're saying is ab
initio we can do a somewhat reasonable
job given this given the connectivity
data given the bond connectivity data
not just given the bag of atoms you've
got to have bond connectivity data yes
I'm not an issue we were who's saying of
it I mean ab initio might mean just with
the atoms and I'm saying forget that you
will have bonds no do you say I mean you
should means can you fly down to
Schrodinger equation yeah that's the
correct I understand that that's what
habanero means for the in there but I'm
saying
Abbe graph I don't know what they've
Latin for graph is but but you know from
the graph from the connectivity graph
right um
so which is which has assumed some kind
of bizarre symbolic representation of
the molecule in terms of bonds I don't
even know whether I mean presumably
there are molecules where it's hard to
even know what you mean by a bond or is
that not the case it's chemistry so
there are exotics yes there are some
situations where you know a three-center
two-electron bond has been postulated to
be the appropriate representation but
we're not trying to deal with those oh
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
before you costs glide over that okay
stream speed okay three electron two
three-center two-electron three atoms
okay so this is money this is like we
don't have a graph we have some kind of
hyper coffee type thing exactly exactly
it's because the the molecule is what's
called fluxional and sometimes the bonds
here and sometimes it's there they're
going back and forth between two
different atoms right well that's life
in quantum mechanics
exactly exactly okay so basically the
whole thing is I mean okay so you know
fundamentally the idea of bonds is kind
of a classical fake okay
they typically it's a bit of literature
on the subject Boulais and all those
Primos it's basically an effect of the
interaction with the infrared sector
that collapses this down so you mean
there is an effective measurement going
on
because of the interaction with what
little radiation yeah okay that's an
interesting claim so so the claim is
that a molecule in a heat bath is
fundamentally a a a semi-classical
system because it is continually being
measured by the heat passes that what
you're saying
that's a little bit stronger but yeah in
this direction and we don't need heat
buzz I mean the vacuum did you know but
like if you every couple atoms it
doesn't flow apart
not even the tender of mass flows apart
because it's permanently measured miss
the infrared vacuum photons I think
that's the modern viewpoint on this I
see I see so what you're saying is so
the question is why does a why does the
hydrogen molecule not have an
uncertainty in its size that grows with
time is that taste that the question oh
that's a nasty I've never thought about
that before and so your claim is that
what are the chemists say about I just
like to think that there's an increased
density of electron between the two
protons that draws them towards the
that's not addressing thinking about the
Shonan right I don't know the philosophy
that comes up between you and Michael
and in these meetings is is sometimes I
don't know is is rods and tubes in AD
riding model you know and they're fixed
permanent to last forever they're
stainless steel they don't rust right
okay but but but but seriously they I
mean you know as we think about building
this for the future what you're saying
is that we could imagine a time in which
there will be it will be relevant to
have a hypergraph as part of the
molecular model I think we could go in
that direction yes
and there's that the way we're
constructing it right now with this
notion of bonds and these special pieces
whatever we're calling them on would
ensemble be appropriate I still like
hyperedge I mean it's some relationship
between multiple vertices yes and hyper
edges I mean but you're talking about
the thing four chiral centers and so on
yes and the thing combining I like
ensemble it has a provenance within
chemistry itself already really for that
[Music]
ensemble is is a group of atoms or a
group of molecules it's not a group of
states like in the canonical ensemble of
statistic
mechanics that's how I know it that's it
there also it's used there also what
about things like well I guess clusters
means of whole molecules and things a
clusters could also be monatomic atoms
or monatomic molecules in a cluster also
you know like neon atoms right I mean
yeah by van der Waals forces but okay
let's see is it looping back for a
second and we really have to wrap this
up yeah
the I mean what we will have to continue
this soon but but okay back to this
thing about so we believe that we will
be able to have reasonable functions
that take a connectivity specified
molecule and actually refine the atomic
positions in that molecule is that
correct there is up to a limit to a
certain size of molecule or there will
be modules where we can't where we will
fail yeah so we won't succeed in
proteins because that requires special
purpose computers and all that and I've
only one person I know who's actually
claims to have succeeded in doing that
in a reasonable way but but well in
these if we want to take a linear chain
of eighty carbon atoms and create a
structure of it then we're gonna have to
to work to make some new functions to do
that right now the library will say what
do people actually care about okay give
me a sense are we talking 100 atoms is
that the size of molecule that we can
deal with or what no I think we can go
larger than that launch several hundred
because there are drug molecules that
are that large when you include
hydrogen's I think we can go that large
I don't think we need to worry about the
de novo structure generation from a
smile string for them I think we can use
a combination of rules heuristics and
distance geometry to tackle that problem
and probably do better than our DK this
is geometry alone okay so is it so give
me a sense let's say you've got a 200
item molecule and it's grinding on a CPU
how much CPU time does it take to come
up with a reasonable solution if you use
heuristics you can do it in a few
seconds
okay and do you get something better if
you're prepared to grind for hours yes
depending on what the method is if you
want to use a force field calculation it
might not necessarily be for hours and
so when when you do this I mean you know
when I've seen actual sort of
simulations of molecules doing their
thing with you know binding sites and so
on the molecule and even in like the you
know the touch press app about molecules
where you can kind of you know where
Te'o simulated them and got got it so
that you can you know use your fingers
on an iPad to move molecule around
there's a high degree of floppiness in
these molecules and I mean how do we
represent that here so we've got atomic
positions but can we represent actually
I wonder how tail represented that for
that app does anybody know no I don't
the peoples interesting to find out
Jason do you know that
so representing that no I've not seen
the app represent the concept of
flexible bounds or rotatable bonds in a
molecule and but guys Jason I can't
believe you have not seen this app this
is the app that tailor-made for touch
press maybe three years ago or something
we did a whole bunch of computational
chemistry to work out for a bunch of
molecules to work out work it out so
that you can literally put your fingers
on an iPad screen and be moving atoms
around if you haven't seen it you should
definitely look at it and play with it
but the question we can ask Thao is how
did he represent molecules because that
would be a really useful thing for us to
have if we're bothering to do all these
computations let's represent the
molecule in such a way that you could in
some you know VR system or something
like that actually do the same thing
that was done in that app and let people
pick up atoms and move them around and
so on you see what I'm saying and have
the molecule actually realistically flop
around
I think given that we're going to the
trouble of computing all the stuff we
should be able to compute I suspect what
you need to computer derivatives or
positions as well as position I've got
code for all of that up there second
derivatives okay and you think that that
will represent I mean because that app
you know you can see like like come
you know I'm so bad at chemistry you
know the actual little rotating
rotatable pieces actually rotating all
the way around it sounds like he's doing
some kind of molecular dynamics
laws of motion along recomputed the
whole point is what he did was he pre
computed that because you don't get to
run that in real time with your fingers
on you know ten positions on an iPad I
know what he's got is a pre computed you
know representation of the molecule of
the molecular structure and you can
interact with it you can you guys you
guys are so I can't believe you guys
don't know this this is a you know I
just have not seen it well you should
see it I'm gonna try it now I've got
this big iPad pro sitting on my desk I
definitely know I'm not I've not tried
it on that so I should be as as
embarrassed as the rest of you for not
having tried it on that thing because if
you can push it and just make the whole
thing spin and its internal motions
continue no every atom moves around
looking like it has it's on a bunch of
Springs and things okay and okay so do
not collide with each other so there's
some you know it doesn't just it's not
just okay
I'm sure that's promotion for it okay
all right we need to all go to a quite
separate and different meeting right
this that we can we can watch to it we
can't we can skip the and you clip into
the half of it you'll see wobbling moley
there you go okay that's not really
doing it well more or less doing it
justice so it's I mean your watch
looking at the results of an MD
simulation no I know but but the whole
point is that you can do that
interactively you can move that around
that's the point that's that's a
non-trivial part and that's why I'm
asking you about um about doing that
okay we got to wrap up here so I don't
know that anybody's watching this but if
you have I hope you had an interesting
time and there'll be another one of
these and maybe if we get to we get good
feedback
about this as a twitch event we will
live stream the next episode and anyway
at least for me it's a great way to
learn something about chemistry
alright I'm talk to everybody in due
course